[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because
i am joined by carly pope aka pope on a
rope aka carly spencer in demonic which
is in theaters and on demand today how
you doing today carly i'm doing really
well steve i just have to say you have
like the best most infectious energy and
i just am here for it so
no
right back at you this is really
exciting to talk to you i feel the good
vibe in the uh zoom room right now yeah
but i'm really excited for you the
film's out today and it's amazing as you
get this awesome lead role in this
awesome film with a huge director in
neil blumkamp who you've worked with
before in elysium now what i'm wondering
is how did you land this big role and
did that have anything to do with it is
there something there with having
experience with this director that got
you it for this
sure sure well i mean there's the
genesis of um from elysium to demonic
was um
was i mean again that was we shot
elysium in
2011 i believe it came out in 2014 but
yeah i think we shot it in 2011.
and
um and you know i was there for like six
or seven days like
like nothing
nothing permanent by any means i had you
know a few
what's ups to neil and thanks for having
me and you know like it was it was a
short exchange you know on a massive
film and i was so it was so cool to be a
part of that but i didn't really you
know i didn't really think
anything of it and i certainly didn't
think that i'd necessarily made an
impression because there just wasn't any
time to so
so then um
in i think it was around
2014 or 2015 neil had this idea to
create oat studios right which was sort
of like his sandbox of doing
experimental content that he could
control and put out himself and
um
and just play with and he wanted to kind
of have like a roving troop of people
that he called on to do these things
because he was he was shooting in
vancouver for the mo for the most part
and um i'm from vancouver i wasn't
living there at the time but uh that's
where i'm from so it's my hometown and i
um
auditioned to be a part of that gaggle
of goons and um
and
uh and and then i and then got the got
the part or parts as it were and so we
did probably about four
or five sort of like shorts together on
oats over like the 2015 to 2017 time i
would say so we had like more exposure
and more experience with one another of
like
how we operate who we are as people
um what we care about
um
and
then so we were in touch over that time
and then like in january of 2020
uh i got an email from him and he just
said look i i kind of want to do like
a horror film
um i don't really i have other things on
the go but like this is a concept that i
that i've been thinking about and i'd
want to do it would you be keen and i
was like yes like
yes of course yes of course like all the
yeses and um
and then when the pandemic shut things
down he was like
he was like more encouraged to do this
film and i just said to him look if you
can figure out how if you can figure out
like the hows and whens and and whats
and
and um
and get me like from america to canada
and we can do this and we're allowed to
do this then yeah for sure
so anyway long long answer is no no no i
love it i could listen you talk all day
this is this is good stuff and that's
but you bring up the pandemic and i was
gonna ask you that too like
what was that like because you are such
an experienced actress
what was that difference you noticed the
most filming during a pandemic like
was that crazy um well i i look i mean
every experience is a new experience
right so it doesn't matter how many how
many like decades of
that i've been around
as an old chewed boot but like it's
doesn't matter like each experience is
going to be new and throw a curveball
you know um i think like it at that
stage we'd been like
the world had had uh received the the
news of rona for about three months or
so so it was there was a lot of nerves
going into you know traveling
quarantining like being on a plane first
of all um
uh being separated from my husband like
like there was a lot of stuff that was
sort of like nerve-wracking about the
experience
um
because we just didn't know you know
like what was set going to look like
what were the protocols they weren't in
place yet in terms of the unions and
stuff like nothing had been sort of
established so so it was all like we
were learning as we went and you know
our our um
production was exceedingly safe we were
shooting also in a small
community in like the interior of
british columbia um we had a very small
cast we had a very small crew so like
everything felt really safe but there
were a lot of unknowns you know there
were a lot of us and and i think that
was again part of the kind of like vibe
part of the like anticipatory vibe that
bled into the film was kind of this like
unknown world
yeah and and yeah you're you're filming
in this crazy world that we're living in
and it's a crazy movie and what's what i
love about this film is like it is that
genre cocktail of horror sci-fi and
actually you get to do everything here
was this in a sense feel like you were
on a different movie every day because
of that like is this like the most fun
gig ever that you could possibly kind of
like get
it was the most fun gig ever that i
could ever possibly get yes like that
like
like no ifs ands or buts about that it's
and that's also i just i love working
with neil like every time has been an
interesting experience every time has
been a different kind of like
a different kind of genre or vibe or
like setting
um you know i've had a i've been it's an
embarrassment of riches every time i get
to work with him because it's it's just
really cool you know it's really really
fun um
[Music]
and
i've forgotten your actual question i'm
so sorry i'm actually no no it's okay
it's just that you see all these
different genres so does it feel like
you're almost on a different movie every
day because you're one day it's hard i
feel like one day it's sci-fi like is
that kind of what's going down yeah no
so so
the thing we we actually like
partitioned it
pretty well like we shot all of the kind
of more sci-fi stuff which is the
simulation world right we shot all of
that
after we'd shot the main like the the
the uh real-time content of the film so
there was a nice separation of those two
things and i am glad about that too
because shooting that stuff
was
particularly science fiction like for me
because it's like you're literally
surrounded by like cameras and wires and
bright lights and metal cages and hard
drives and screens and i was like oh my
god
yeah oh yeah but you know like it was it
was such a vibe it was so there was so
much like electrical
activity
that um that then having to do like the
emotional like powerhouse scenes of the
film like that's where like you know
that's where carly's getting gut punched
in like in those sequences
so it was it was a really it was a
really trippy experience to go from
you know to to to learn how to like
amalgamate and and and negotiate that uh
world
but that that's interesting too because
doing all that but also like you just
mentioned this emotional story of carly
and that we see with no spoilers at the
core of the story though is a story
about a mother-in-daughter relationship
did you find yourself relating to that
at all was this something that was heavy
duty to get into the mindset of as the
character of carl yeah well you know i
think that like i mean i'm i'm very very
blessed my mom is still around and she's
my favorite person and i i love her
dearly and um
but the notion of
someone being estranged from their
mother
and perhaps running out of time
to
find a resolution
for that rift was a really compelling
draw to me because i was like
that in itself would be horrifying to me
like that in itself would be so painful
and so hard
so
um so i thought that was really
interesting and i and i knew
also
like as a result carly is a very like
withdrawn isolated person like like she
is like she's done that she's she's
enclosed herself in
you know and in order to
in order to heal
any of that past she has to be really
open and vulnerable
and allow
the experience to wash over her in order
to get to the other side
you know and i
i thought that that was um
you know i thought that was a good
reminder and a good lesson as a human
that like being vulnerable is okay it's
a nice thing yeah feeling feelings
100 and that's just a good lesson and
one of the themes you'll see in this
movie and you see just from how
impressive you talk about this character
how well you know them so i'm wondering
too
do choices like even having
pink highlights in your hair is that a
character choice or is it just badass
like oh it's cool i dig this like how
does that even come about i always
wondered things like that because now
everyone's going to get those you know
yeah i had hair i would i don't have
hair yeah no it's um
you know that was sort of a choice that
was based on a little bit of like an
anachronistic element of the film where
you know like like neil
neil when we were first going he's like
like i'm like he's like general
aesthetic
is rona which is like a home hardware
store
sure sure on that it was like general
aesthetic moscow 91.
like
so
there's
like we had this kind of anachronistic
element to it but there was also
obviously in terms of like the clothing
choices in terms of like the hair
in terms of the car like there's a there
are there's a little bit of like stuck
in the past
you know sure there is that in the past
vibe but the other thing too that i
liked and and this was this was
important for me was that
you know carly carly has been so
withdrawn and so closed in and so um
so like she's retreated so much from the
world
i kind of liked the idea that that she
dyes her hair this color which is kind
of like a cry for help in the sense of
like she wants to be seen she wants
there's something loud and reactionary
about it even though she's like held
herself so tight
inward you know sure so i thought that
was kind of an interesting paradox so
are you talking about carly the
character or yourself in third person
right now well well steve
let me tell you i have a few piercings a
few tattoos and i've been known to dye
my hair strange colors and i was
actually going to last week and i'm glad
i didn't but
okay but that i make that comment
because i also this is another weird
random question but i think of these
things i think people think it's like
your character being named carly and
your name being carly in real life does
that bring a challenge in itself because
does it take you out of a character
maybe if like someone's saying carly but
you're thinking of your character carly
does that
ever even come into play
yeah you know what it's so weird because
i would have thought yes like i would
have thought it would have been really
hard but
i think you know i'd cut off my hair
i had i had dyed it like there was
enough of like a character
on who i am as a person that i really
just felt like i felt like i could step
into carly spencer's shoes um or like
converse in this case
you know no problem like i've i felt
like it was it was it was it was okay
and and there were also elements of like
you know trauma and withdrawal that i as
a person have also experienced and i i
was really keen to mine that stuff that
i was like
it didn't
it didn't like that
it didn't distract i guess to answer
your question it didn't distract me that
the name was the same i still don't know
why neil chose to keep it the same all
said and done i don't know because he
was originally born out of um originally
the concept of the film before we
before the pandemic like originally when
he first emailed me about it he was sort
of like i want to do like a you know a
low budget horror film kind of like a
found footage paranormal activity blair
witch like terrifying
you know film like that so i think the
original idea was like our own names
because it was going to be that
i know
okay
but then it became an actual scripted
narrative feature
and so there was there was no need now
to keep it that so i'm not sure if he
was just like you know i'm not sure what
he was up to there but
no i mean that look all these answers
you're giving are incredible i wish i
could talk to you longer but people who
are watching are enjoying you i mean now
they can go watch you in demonic it's in
theaters today and on demand
carly thank you so much for joining me
and i hope to talk to you in the future
one day i hope so too steve i i it would
be a pleasure it's so nice to uh to meet
you here and i appreciate you having me
on